[Music] this is Hudson as you can see he's pretty excited about being at the beach today however there is a bylaw in place on how the beaches in the Weimar kadhi are used and includes some pretty key rules for us dog owners dogs are welcome at most features in the Weimar cadet II however they're not allowed around the Ashley Rucker hoodie estuary in wetlands that's to safeguard the local bird habitat dogs also aren't allowed within the surf flags or within 50 meters of the surf legs and around horses on the beach dogs must be under effective control if they can't be controlled by your voice and they must be put on a leash it's really simple and as always make sure you bring along plenty of these to clean up after your furry friend we've all got a part to play in preserving our beaches in estuary find out more at Waimea daddy govt T&Z [ __ ] / beaches [Music] you